your hand changes for a second and not
that and it's not some magic loop you do
that your hookahs arm stays out there
there there is energy working between
the two grips do you feel that okay not
not like that
it's where he gets stuck okay
and so this friction here is working
with this friction here and so this hand
can move you see but it's still keeping
it in place okay so you can still do
throws not it's dead here I'm holding it
is dead
so energy between the two hands and you
can get that technically though okay so
don't let this hand go down
oh you should have this Center with
those two hats Center with those two
Napa so it looks like I'm letting go but
I'm not because I'm not grip dependent
on the other technique its energy
dependent it's an energetic relationship
between the two hands his arm his
attention his inertia okay his
gravitational pull all that keeps that
hand there he's he's not holding it
there for me or me molded in there
for for me okay energy is what's holding
it there okay got it
so these these techniques when I come
around is how you can do disarm so we're
gonna work it that way here okay it's
not me going like that okay boom here I
get the energy I'll come around here
around I'm not doing anything I'm just
around I find the opening here boom
okay boom Kitty grip boom come
underneath over the top home energy in
here energy energy still energy that
nice gonna make me not want to let go
you see energy energy energy energy okay
let's try this this is that energies for
the disarm one so if you let it go this
hand is feeding that energy you see that
okay so it's feeding it I don't mean to
grab it it's feeding me this hand is
feeding the elbow hand do you see do you
feel that yeah I'm gonna take one energy
off see the difference not as tight
right elbow hun is off the energy I'm
gonna put the energy on and it goes into
your Center do you feel that I'm using
his Center to generate friction into two
hands you see that you feel that okay so
when I come around you're gonna lose all
that if you let that whole thing go down
you so you're going to move into that
whole thing it's still the same thing
you feel it okay it's still the same
thing full again so everything is in
place boom is still there it doesn't
matter what I'm touching with it we're
how I'm touching with it it's all the
same okay try it again so remember it's
three points
the two hats must be pulling on the
center that's why you have the Kazushi -
okay so I'm not going to go like this
he kept keeps his hand there for me
right he's gonna be goofy so I'm gonna
go to trial I'm gonna go slow as they
keep moving right so he's trying to get
up and I'm gonna take this
reconciliation this way do you see how
did not but it's the same kind of thing
it's not me holding this or him holding
his arm up and I get to do that kinda if
the friction is already there can you
see that
so don't go dead here no it's pulling on
a center the two hounds are pulling on a
center do you feel that now we're stuck
we're stuck and now I can do the Hat
change boom okay I'm trying